this is this is some very very important
news up at the top here with the zodiac
killer apparently they figured out who
the zodiac killer was and i guess i
don't know probably maybe they found him
boarding a plane uh headed to cancun i
mean it's a possibility right i think
that could be a possibility you know the
snow lizard ted cruz everyone thinks he
was a zodiac killer and if you compare
the pictures of the person who the
authorities think the zodiac killer is
which i guess he's been dead for
like three years now or something
i don't even remember his name it was
like schmed schmidt schmooze or
something like that i i don't know it
was
some weird name but
anyways he's he looks very similar it
looks like um ted cruz
uh and and this guy fidel castro and
probably the guy who shot jfk could all
probably be the exact same person or at
least like quadruplets that's probably
what it is they were probably
quadruplets at one point or something
maybe maybe it's a reincarnation type
thing um and speaking of ted cruz
that [ __ ] [ __ ] bag
he did get in front of a microphone
today and make a complete [ __ ] fool
out of himself
who could have thought ted cruz would
say some stupid [ __ ] into a microphone
he goes down to texas he's trying to
talk about the border he's trying to
drum up more [ __ ] instead of going
to washington and doing his [ __ ] job
and passing immigration reform and
getting some sort of immigration reform
instituted in this country that [ __ ]
works that isn't [ __ ] absolutely
[ __ ] broken
the guy goes down and and just points at
the problem says it's your problem not
mine elected officials who's not me you
do something about it
like literally this guy is a united
states senator in one of the largest
border states of mexico he is the
senator he's the sitting [ __ ] senator
from texas he's the guy that would be in
the senate him or john cornyn would be
the guys in the senate saying hey we
need to do something about the border in
my state
on the floor of the senate chamber
where reform and policy can actually be
made so it can be changed because hey
bonehead the executive branch only has
so much leeway here
on instituting policy that you create
through legislation you dumb
[ __ ]
so why don't you why don't you hop
instead of hopping on a plane to cancun
which we all would like that just go to
cancun and [ __ ] stay there or get on
a [ __ ] plane go back to washington
and do your [ __ ] job why don't you
instead of standing in front of a
microphone trying to act like you feel
sorry for people who got shot in high
school because your stupid [ __ ] state
including you think it's a good idea to
give everyone and anyone guns everyone
six-year-olds 12-year-olds high
schoolers i mean [ __ ] let's let them
carry them in their backpacks that way
when they get in a scuffle they can just
shoot each other i mean the good guys
with the guns are always always always
going to make sure to get rid of the bad
guys with the guns right because i know
this is going to be their argument this
is always their [ __ ] argument good
guy bad guy [ __ ]
uh mental illness [ __ ] i mean it's
always it's always the same [ __ ] [ __ ]
i did a video a long ago a tic tac long
ago about i called it the mental
amendment
because they always do that rather it's
a semi-automatic rifle or it's a [ __ ]
handgun whatever it is when we have one
of these shootings they always trudge
out the same old [ __ ] worn out
[ __ ] [ __ ] arguments of why we
can't have gun control when they should
just say hey we want to make sure gun
manufacturers can sell you guns and a
lot of them and we don't and they pay us
money to make sure they can sell you
guns that's what it is it has nothing to
do with safety has nothing to do with
protection that's all [ __ ] if they
would just say that i would be okay with
it i would be okay like oh okay you are
[ __ ] idiots but they give all these
stupid [ __ ] excuses that don't make
any [ __ ] sense i believe that
americans are [ __ ] tired of this
[ __ ] completely [ __ ] tired of
this [ __ ]
these [ __ ] arguments that have no
[ __ ] logic or critical thinking when
it comes to guns or anything else for
that matter because we're gonna see josh
holly make a [ __ ] fool of himself
today about school about these facebook
school board domestic terrorists that
are running around and running rampant
throughout our country in our
communities
and they're
they're terrorizing uh elected officials
and also [ __ ] hospitals doctors and
nurses for crying out loud it's the same
[ __ ] doing the same [ __ ]
they're terrorists they're domestic
terrorist is what they are they're using
intimidation and terrorist tactics to
try to move the ball in their direction
but
i want to play a clip here of ted cruz
because he was in texas today because he
was trying to talk about the border and
he tries to have i don't know it's
[ __ ] weird i don't know if he's
trying to do a moment of silence or
or what he really he didn't have a very
good
he obviously had a speech written of the
the toxic rhetoric about the immigration
and the border that he wanted to spew
into a microphone so we got the facebook
fans all riled up that way maybe he
could appear on tucker carlson or sean
hannity tonight and get a clip of
himself puking into a [ __ ] microphone
it [ __ ] fascist that's that's exactly
what he was trying to do but then this
school shooting happened and god damn it
that inconvenience is ted cruz because
now he's got to go on the fly and kind
of make up some [ __ ] and look
disingenuous i mean god damn that that
isn't good for politics i just i just
want to get the [ __ ] the highlights
on fox news the oan highlights the
newsmax highlights i want to please the
facebook fans but let's watch the
[ __ ] clip of this [ __ ]
and there have been far too many of
these at far too many schools